[Music]
the fascinating piece of the news the
other day where they actually found a
cave painting in an Indonesian island
that is up to 40 thousand years old it's
the oldest cave painting that's ever
been found by man again 40,000 years I'm
just the thought that human beings have
been trying to exteriorize their minds
and and symbolically represent
themselves for 40,000 years that the
human imagination was pulsating for
hours and years ago that there was
enough agitation and of a desire to
transfigure ate the contents from within
and translate them to the spaces of
without to external eyes ourselves to
project to represent the urge to
represent that symbolic capacity of man
has been here for 40,000 years I just
find that absolutely mind-boggling it's
one of those things that makes you
wonder
what I want to walk it what guys just
one of those one of those mysteries
[Music]
you